so we have a new bribery corruption
story about Donald Trump Donald Trump is
now being accused of having promised
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange a
pardon if he were to publicly deny
Russia's involvement in the hacking of
the DNC back during the 2016 election
which of course would have been a lie
because we know that that is exactly the
way it went down
every aspect of this story is pure
corruption and it's down to the details
exactly what we would expect it even
involves congressman Russia the former
that's the nickname for the former
congressman dana rohrabacher who is also
tied up in this entire thing so this is
not Trump's Ukraine Biden corruption
extortion bribery this is not Trump
funneling money from taxpayers and
donors through the Secret Service into
his own hotels and resorts we've talked
about that this is not other emoluments
violations by Donald Trump we've talked
about that this is a new corruption
story about Donald Trump
so it's widely accepted that Russia
hacked the DNC back during the 2016
election Donald Trump has been very
eager to question or deny that since day
one because it fuels the narrative that
Russia preferred Trump over Hillary
Clinton which we of course now know to
be true as well Julian Assange is the
founder of WikiLeaks he is now under
arrest he's facing extradition
previously had been holed up to avoid
arrest in the Ecuadorian Embassy in
London for years and years to avoid that
extradition
eventually he overstayed his welcome
there were allegations about hygiene and
all sorts of other stuff in any case at
some point the Ecuadorian embassy said
No Mas so Julian Assange's lawyer now
asserts in court during a pre
extradition hearing that Donald Trump
through proxies offered Julian Assange a
pardon if he were to agree to help cover
up the truth of the Russia hack meaning
Trump wanted Assange to sow
disinformation seeking to distance
Russia from the DNC hack and this is a
mind-blowing allegation the person who
allegedly communicated the offer to
Julian Assange was none other than
former Republican congressman Dana
Rohrabacher
a guy himself known for his sketchy
connections to Russia Rohrabacher went
to London in 2017 to make this offer it
is alleged Rohrabacher widely known as
congressman Russia and as Putin's
favorite congressman the claim was made
in court that quote mr. Rohrabacher
going to see mr. Assange and sang on
instructions of the president that he
was offering a pardon or some other way
out if Assange said Russia had nothing
to do with the DNC leaks the White House
was asked about this allegation and they
issued a very carefully worded denial
check it out a Stephanie Grisham the
White House press secretary who we never
see cuz she doesn't do press briefings
said quote the president barely knows
Dana Rohrabacher other than he's an ex
congressman he's never spoken to him on
this subject or almost any subject it is
a complete fabrication and a total lie
this is probably another never-ending
hoax and total lie from the DNC notice
that the statement says Trump barely
knows Rohrabacher well you don't have to
know him at all to get him to
communicate a possible pardon to Julian
Assange the statement says Trump has
never spoken to Rohrabacher about this
of course any number of middlemen could
have passed along the message to
Rohrabacher and then they blame the DNC
completely without evidence which of
course has nothing to do with this as
far as we know this is an assertion that
was made in a British Court by the
lawyer of Julian Assange and there is
nothing to do with the DNC as far as we
currently have evidence this isn't the
first time that Rohrabacher
trip to London was asserted to be
connected to an Assange pardon two
months after this trip happened The Wall
Street Journal reported what Rohrabacher
was doing in that trip was trying to
arrange a deal for Donald Trump to
pardon Julian Assange so it's not even
the first time that that has been
suggested the White House confirmed at
the time that Rohrabacher had spoken to
Donald Trump's chief of staff John Kelly
about the plan
to free Julian Assange but it wasn't
clear who had personally spoken to whom
did Trump speak to Rohrabacher or not
but it doesn't really matter because you
don't need to have a direct conversation
for the assertion to be true The Daily
Beast says that in 2018 Rohrabacher told
the intercept that he was blocked from
discussing the plan with the president
because Kelley and others thought it
would look like collusion so case in
point when the White House says Trump
never spoke to Rohrabacher about it we
have a report from The Daily Beast that
says they were deliberately
communicating through others to avoid it
looking like they were colluding on this
so is this believable of course it is do
we have reason to doubt it well with any
of these stories we should apply a
healthy level of skepticism in this case
we have reports from two different news
agencies in the past combined now with
the assertions by Julian Assange his
lawyer and the fact that this is how
Donald Trump is known to work Trump has
implicitly suggested that people who
keep their mouths shut about him could
get a pardon calling them strong people
who don't crack like Paul Manafort you
might remember Trump has withheld aid to
Ukraine unless they smear Biden he got
caught and ultimately had to release the
aide this is how Donald Trump has always
done business as a real estate developer
in New York down to the details this is
how Trump operates and in the end we go
back to if there's nothing wrong if
there's nothing with Russia here why
again is there more of an effort
uncovered that was geared towards hiding
Russia's involvement in that DNC hack
and like I told you yesterday Trump and
pardons these are political tools that
he uses and he will keep using them to
his advantage if he is re-elected to a
second term that you can be sure of one
of our sponsors today is VIN Chara
watches giving you 15% off your entire
order when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch don't pay thousands of
dollars for a high-quality watch that
looks great because you don't have to
all event arrows watches are made with
high-end materials masterfully built and
they look like something you'd spend a
ton of money on but every venture oh
watch ranges from about a hundred and
fifty to three hundred bucks I went over
to their website and picked out the
bellwether in silver and white really
nice elegant look it's a coronagraph
style wore it to a gala over the weekend
and a lot of people asked me where's the
watch from really really great look
totally different they also sent me the
altitude in matte black and red a much
more rugged view of what a watch can
look like really liked it as well as
well as the athletic strap it's a new
year it's a new decade it's time to
re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high-quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch